with an investigation into the funding
and finances of the Scottish national
party
also this hour business confidence on
the up in the latest economic survey but
most companies aren't seeing an
improvement in sales
new car sales continue their recovery as
registrations grow for the eighth month
in a row
of con calls for an investigation into
the UK's Market in cloud services
plus the world's first material that
becomes thicker rather than thinner when
stretched
[Music]
good morning this is in King live in our
business and economic news from the
Heart of the City where we start with
some breaking news the former Scottish
national party chief executive Peter
Morrell is understood to have been
arrested by police Scotland over an
investigation into the party's finances
Peter Murrell of course is the husband
of the former first Minister Nicholas
sturgeon our political correspondent
Tamara Cohen is in Westminster now
tomorrow there have been a lot of rumors
about this police investigation in
particular there were fundraisings in
2017 and 2019 that appear to be the
focus of police Scotland's
investigations
that's right Ian and although there have
been Rumblings about this it's still a
pretty dramatic development this morning
that police Scotland have arrested a 58
year old man we understood to be Peter
Murrell
um the husband of Nicholas sturgeon and
part of the power couple at the top of
Scottish politics for so many years he's
been arrested as part of the
investigation into what we're told is
the funding and finances of the SMP and
also officers are carrying out searches
and a number of addresses as part of
that investigation yes there are
questions about around six hundred
thousand pounds that was raised by SMP
supporters for essentially a second
referendum and whether that money was
spent there's also been questions for Mr
Morrill about a loan he was reported to
have given the SMP in 2021 during a time
of cash flow problems now you'll
remember he actually stepped down as
chief executive just over two weeks ago
after a route about the smp's membership
and
um whether the fact that it had dropped
by 30 000 over the past year although
senior people from the SMP was told to
say publicly that it hadn't now Nicholas
sturgeon welcomed him stepping down
saying he'd taken responsibility but
she's always distanced herself from any
questions about the party's finances and
you wonder if this is going to be a
considerable Turning Point especially if
Nicholas sturgeon herself is dragged
into this investigation at all given the
fact that police are rape there's no
suggestion of it at the moment but given
the fact that police are reading
properties as part of it so pretty
dramatic investigation and we understand
Mr Morrill is being questioned by
detectives at the moment absolutely
worth reminding viewers tomorrow that
Peter mole have been chief executive of
the SMP since 1999. he was a very very
long-standing figure and therefore
probably uh more deeply uh involved in
the parties his finances and any other
one individual
absolutely yes he's been there for 25
years and his wife Nicholas sturgeon was
first minister of course and then Deputy
first Minister
um for 16 years so these two have really
been at the top of the SMP for a very
long time and it presents a big dilemma
for the new first Minister uh Hamza
Yusuf I mean he described Peter Murrell
during the smp's recent leadership
contest as an election winner he helped
bring about the many election victories
the SMP have secured over the years so
how far he distances himself from Miss
sturgeon and Mr moral given that he was
one of their close allies and what he
says about this investigation is going
to be um really critical we know that Mr
Youssef as first Minister has promised
more transparency but it's been a time
of extraordinary turmoil for the SMP and
I'm sure labor and the conservatives
will be rubbing their hands I mean the
conservative chairman said at the time
that Mr moral stood down in this
membership row a couple of weeks ago
that a fish rots from the head and
that's what's happening to the SMP labor
talked about the wheels falling off the
SMP wagon it's not going to be easy to
override the smp's dominance of Scottish
politics but certainly this uh the
arrest of Peter Murrell and implications
for Nicholas sturgeon put it in probably
the most serious position the SMP have
been in since they took over in since
they've been holding the position of
first minister in 2007. yeah worth
pointing out tomorrow that not everyone
in the SMP was happy with the
arrangements I mean Joanna Cherry who's
a prominent smpmp was very very critical
of the fact that you had a party leader
and its chief executive who were a
husband and wife couple
she was and there were others who said
so to varying extents even during the
leadership contest he saw more criticism
of of the last how the SMP have handled
the last few months for example from
Kate Forbes who didn't didn't win but
came close in the leadership contest she
talked about a ton of extraordinary
turmoil and needing to win back people's
trusts so there have been Jitters among
the SMP especially when some of these
Financial questions came to light a
couple of years ago but I think the
extent to which Nicola sturgeon has
tried to distance herself from this
issue she was asked about it at the
press conference when she announced that
she was stepping down and essentially
said she was nothing to do with it if it
turns out that she is or that more was
known to her than she let on I think it
could be very damaging for the couple
who've been so dominant in Scottish
politics so unassailable for such a long
time
tomorrow just for the for the benefit of
people who may not be in in the weeds
with this story of course it's worth
pointing out that all of this really
began when the Electoral commission
started looking at SMP finances do we
have any sort of readouts on the what
conclusions they may have drawn
so all we've been told by police
Scotland Ian is that um that they're
looking into the funding and finances of
the SMP so we don't know exactly what
they are questioning uh Peter Murrell
about but certainly um there have been
um questions about in particular this
600 000 pounds of donations they were
essentially ring fenced
um as a fund for a second referendum and
we know that of course the SMP um have
tried and failed to secure that that
second referendum and there are now
questions about what exactly happened to
that money and that these questions have
been going on uh for some time added to
which is another another question about
a loan that Mr Morrill is said to have
given the SMP
um uh two years ago in 2021 so all of
this has been a question for some time
and we know the information was passed
to the crown office a month a month ago
alleging that some of this money had
gone missing Nicholas surgeon said she
was not concerned about the party's
finances when she was asked about it but
certainly many others in the SMP were
and it sounds as if the police now have
enough evidence to put to Mr Morrill who
was arrested this morning
okay stay with us sir tomorrow just want
to uh draw the attention of you as to
what's going on on the right hand side
of the screen there which is uh the
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
has arrived in the Polish capital of uh
Warsaw where he appears to be meeting uh
military uh leaders and other
dignitaries right now we'll get a bit of
uh reaction to that in due course but uh
tomorrow going back to the uh loan that
Peter Murrell made to the SMP it was in
the order of a hundred and seven
thousand Pounds what was that money
spent on do we know
foreign
s yes sorry this 107 000 pound uh loan
which Nicholas sturgeon has been
repeatedly questioned about when she
knew when she first knew her husband had
given it and she said I can't recall
exactly when I knew that we don't know
exactly what the loan was spent on we
know it was a time of
um financial difficulty
um for the for the SNP
um they had recently gone through uh
their holyrood elections
um they had lost a few msps and they
were struggling to get their plans for a
second referendum off the ground and we
know that they um there was we don't
know exactly what it was spent on and um
they're also of course relates to
questions about where the money for the
second referendum ended up going
um and all of these I assume will form
part of the police investigation but I
think a very ominous line in that police
Scotland statement is that officers are
conducting searches add a number of
properties and so I think one of the big
questions of the coming days is whether
Nicholas sturgeon herself will be
further embroiled in this well you
mentioned those searches tomorrow I
think we may have a still of the of
police Scotland uh conducting one of
those uh those visits to premises
anytime that's going to pop up on the uh
on the screen here I think that 107 000
pound loan tomorrow incidentally all
that was said about it by uh the party
at the time was that it was for working
capital purposes there we go that is the
scene uh regular viewers will recognize
that that looks very much like the
residential property outside which uh
Nicholas sturgeon was interviewed fairly
recently when she stepped down as first
minister so that is a shot from those
premises
um tomorrow you were talking just now
about the new first Minister Hamza Yusuf
I mean he was obviously presented during
the uh the leadership campaign as being
the the continuity candidate but I guess
this does potentially give him the
opportunity for a sort of root and
Branch uh shake-up of SMP headquarters
should he so wish
I think he'll be under pressure to do
that yes he was very much seen as an
ally of Nicholas sturgeon Nicholas
sturgeon we must add did Welcome her
husband's resignation on the 18th of
March saying he'd obviously taken
responsibility for the issues um with
the membership but um Hamza Yusuf said
in the summer that he regarded Peter
Murrell as an election winner someone
who'd been crucial to the SMP machine as
it was so electorally successful in
Scotland I think it will be up to him
now to bring the greater transparency
that he talked about when he became
first Minister and um it's been a time
of extraordinary turmoil for the SMP
over the last few weeks I think he's got
many many challenges coming up not least
a difficult by-election on the horizon
in uh in West Hamilton but he's also now
got the challenge of trying to overhaul
some of the processes and that work may
have to wait now until the police
conclude their inquire is and we see
whether anyone else Beyond Mr moral is
implicated in this investigation
tomorrow are you surprised that uh at
this the timing of this particular
development I mean it's been well known
that people have been looking into the
funding of the SMP for quite a while now
it is well known in the investigation
yes you're right has been going on for a
couple of years now but it's still been
a very dramatic development this morning
I don't think we were expecting
um that Peter Murrell has been taken
into custody and um I don't think
anyone's making any any claims about the
timing of it at the moment but certainly
if you just look at how things have
changed in Scottish politics over the
last few weeks we had the extremely
surprising resignation of Nicholas
sturgeon in February we've had this
leadership contest in which really the
gloves came off you know the SMP had
been so disciplined over the years
um in in you know holding it together
despite their differences we saw a lot
of that burst out into the open in the
leadership contest we now have the
party's most senior back room figure
Peter Murrell you know someone who was
all over the party's organization and
financing he is now being questioned by
detectives and there will be a very big
job to do to rebuild Trust in the SMP
and I think some of those like Joanna
Terry who you mentioned who had been
critical of some of the internal
Arrangements that had not been listened
to I think they may now start to speak
out publicly as well and of course
Scottish conservatives and labor who
both hoping to win seats in Scotland at
the next election will probably be
rubbing their hands at this development
so um in the history of the SMP the last
few months has been probably the biggest
low Point since they really started to
build up support in Scotland
um well over 15 years ago
okay tomorrow thanks for that we would
of course keep you abreast of any new
information we get on this breaking news
story the arrest of Nicholas sturgeon's
husband Peter Murrell by police Scotland
this morning with regards to an
investigation into the finances of the
Scottish national party before we uh
crack on with the business news we're
just going to cross over to Warsaw where
president zielinski of Ukraine is being
welcomed on his first visit to Poland
since the Russian invasion our Europe
correspondent Siobhan Robbins is on the
scene Siobhan what's uh happening right
now
well we have seen president zielinski
arriving in Poland in the last few hours
he's now gone to the presidential Palace
where he's meeting the Polish president
you can see that they're giving him this
big ceremonial welcome he's been walking
in front of the troops the first ladies
both there as well you can see in the
pictures watching as the band goes past
and this is part of a first official
visit to Poland by president zielinski
of course a very important partner for
the ukrainians since this invasion of
Ukraine Poland has been extremely vocal
in their support for Ukraine not just in
terms of calling on other allies to send
weapons and sending weapons themselves
but also in welcoming ukrainians who
have left because of the war they've
taken in more than a million Ukrainian
refugees so part of the reason for this
visit is for president zolenski to say
thank you and also to talk about going
forward so no about other things that
they'll discuss on the agenda of courses
Finland joining NATO they'll probably
also be talking about weapons going
forward we know that President zielinski
still wants more arms different types of
arms to be sent more different types of
fighter jets to be sent so they'll be
discussing that I expect but there are
more tricky issues on the agenda as well
this morning I understand that local
reports are saying that the agricultural
Minister here has resigned and that's
because of a big problem that's facing
polish Farmers to do with Ukrainian
grain it's been flooding across the
border here pushing down prices that's
led to a lot of problems for Polish
Farmers so they're trying to organize
some sort of deal about that we've got
the band just going past us now as the
president's head inside for a hefty day
of talks then meeting with the Prime
Minister and then this evening a big
meeting again with both Polish people
who've helped you trainers and also
local ukrainians who've moved here
okay thanks Jerome
and more breaking news and in the last
hour figures have been published
suggesting that the UK Services sector
continue to grow last month the
purchasing managers index survey data
published by s p Global in which
anything above 50 represents growth and
anything below that a contraction came
in at 52.9 for March that was down from
53.5 in February but still consistent
with growth for s p Global said the
Figures were supported by the fastest
increase in New Order volumes for a year
which reflected greater confidence among
clients in both domestic and
international markets and we're going to
stay with that theme now because more
than half of UK firms some 52 percent
believe their turnover will rise over
the next 12 months that's the good news
the bad news is that just one in three
firms have seen their turnover increase
during the first three months of this
year while a majority see no improvement
in business conditions well those are
the main findings in the latest
quarterly economic survey from the
British Chambers of Commerce whose
director General Siobhan Haviland joins
me now Siobhan welcome to you I mean on
the whole there appears to be a bit more
or optimism around yeah it's nice to see
a bit of an uplift in confidence there
Ian in this quarter remember we are
coming from last year where it was
particularly difficult political
instabilities spiraling energy costs and
of course talk of a recession at the end
of last year so the beginning of this
year is definitely seeing more positive
news that confidence is good
we are yet to see that sort of filter
through to sales or an uplift in
investment
um and we are still hearing from
businesses that the
trouble getting people in labor and the
energy bills are a challenge but good to
see some increase in confidence yeah I
mean when we talk when you ask members
about an increase in turnover are we
talking here about a genuine rise in
sales volumes or activity or just
numbers that have been flattered by a
bit of inflation so I mean that turnover
number is looking ahead so they're
looking ahead in a positive way
they're definitely telling us that there
is some positive demand I was in
Huddersfield and Worcester last week
talking to Business Leaders uh and they
talk about that positive increase in
demand but they then go quite quickly
back to but I'm really struggling to
find the people to fulfill those orders
and I'm still worried about energy
because remember this month we are
seeing a massive reduction in energy
support well quite I mean are you
surprised that the government didn't do
more in the recent Budget on that front
we really wanted to see more on that
front we're seeing 85 reduction in
support for energy bills for businesses
whereas of course consumers you know got
another three months which is very good
uh but energy bills you know those are
two sides of the same core and
effectively and a lot of smaller
businesses buy energy like consumers do
so
government's saying Energy prices are
coming down hopefully we will see that
being passed through to businesses
because that's the other concern well
quite I mean Energy prices aren't coming
down since uh since the weekend no PEX
production cut I mean the price of Brent
crude has gone by up by about nearly
nine ten percent again yeah and you
remember we're coming from a point of
businesses telling us that their energy
bills have gone up 200 300 I mean
they're eye-watering numbers and that is
just sucking cash out of their Bank
balances and that is why businesses are
investing now holding on to the cash
because they're still worried about
their energy bills you know and other
tax Rises that we're seeing come in this
month the one encouraging thing in the
server though is that more than
two-fifths of companies expect profits
to rise this year yeah yeah and that's
that's related to obviously that that
confidence
hoping energy
they're going to come at least move
downward inflation's heading in the
right direction the first time you know
out of eight different last eight
quarters inflations you know concerns
about inflation have reduced so that's a
good thing you know we're seeing that
coming down well we hope to see that
coming down as the year goes on so those
are optimistic which of the sectors
where you're seeing most optimism among
members right now I presume that there's
a real diversity of opinion yeah there
really is I mean the sector's suffering
the most are still hospitality and
Retail of course this quarter is one of
their hardest quarters in terms of
January and February sales
um but they're also hugely more impacted
by those energy bills and by the
difficulty of getting people you know if
I talk to hospitality industry around
the country there none of them are
working at 100 service levels in hotels
are closing floors restaurants are
reducing their hours it's still really
hard and that of course is also pushing
out wages you talked a lot just now
about the labor market and uh labor
shortages do you get any sort of inkling
that things are starting to improve I
mean we hear that some over 50s in
particular are now starting to return to
the labor market so we've still got 1.1
million open roles in this country
um yes there were some positive news in
the budget from the chancellor about
child care but that doesn't kick in
until next April what we really want to
see is the government do more on
shortage occupation lists and this is
the way they can bring short-term labor
into the market to ease the problems as
we grow hopefully out of this situation
all right you've all got to leave it
there great to see you this morning
thank you thanks very much
some other business news stories for you
now and the telecoms regulator ofcom is
to ask the competition and markets
authority to open an investigation into
the UK's Market in cloud services ofcom
said a market study it had carried out
had provisionally identified features
and practices that make it more
difficult for customers to switch and
use multiple Cloud suppliers it said it
was particularly concerned about the
practices of Amazon and Microsoft
because of their Market position well
the pair are estimated to have a
combined market share of between 60 to
70 percent with Google their nearest
competitor back on between five to ten
percent of the market
The Cooperative group has maintained
annual profits despite difficulties in
its Insurance arm underlying operating
profit for 2022 came in at 100 million
pounds that was unchanged from 2021 with
sales in its food and wholesaling
funeral care and legal services
divisions or increasing income in its
Insurance business however fell due to
contraction in the motor insurance
Market well Alan Layton the co-op's
chairman said it was an encouraging
performance given the inflationary
challenges facing most consumer-facing
businesses the Cope's headline pre-tax
profits by the way surged from 57
million pounds to 247 million pounds
that was following the sale of its
petrol forecourt business in October
last year
the game in group entain is buying the
Israeli sports results application 365
scores for 120 million pounds and Tain
which owns the bookmakers lab Brooks and
coral as well as other betting and
gaming Brands including sporting bet in
Gala Bingo said the acquisition would
provide customers with a broader
offering of interactive content and
experiences well 365 scores which was
founded by four former comrades from the
Israeli Armed Forces provide scores and
sports information editorial and social
content and sports Focus free-to-play
games to more than 15 million active
users
and the drugs giant AstraZeneca said
this morning that clinical trials
involving a combination of two of its
Cancer Treatments had proved effective
in treating Advanced high-grade
epithelial ovarian cancer well the
company said that combining limpaza
which is an existing ovarian cancer
treatment and infinzi which is a
treatment for bladder cancer had shown
statistically significant and clinical
clinically meaningful improvements in
progression-free survival rates when
patients had also received chemotherapy
and an existing treatment
Now new car sales Rose in March for the
eighth consecutive month well it was the
biggest ever month for battery electric
car registrations the monthly new car
registration figures from the Society of
motor manufacturers and Traders revealed
that new registrations were up 18.2
percent on March last year it said this
was partly due to surgeon deliveries for
large fleets which accounted for nearly
49 of new registrations during the month
for joining me as my cause he's the
chief executive of the smmt Mike good to
see you this morning I mean March is
always a big month because it's a new
plate month but uh even so this is a
pretty strong showing it is I mean we
were pleasantly surprised at just how
strong it is I mean we have been growing
as you said for a number of months but
March is a critical month it kind of
sets the tone for the year we do have to
put into perspective so 18 growth I mean
is fantastic given the current economic
conditions but we're still about 37
below the pre-pandemic level so show
just how far we've got to get back
towards recovery so what's been driving
this is it the fact that March is a big
new play a month is there more choice
for consumers and then more products
coming onto the market it's all of the
above but I think the biggest issue is
you'll be given we've had such a
constrained Supply production even
shortage of semiconductors and other
supply chain parts for two or three
years now partly what predominant you
the pandemic that is gradually beginning
to ease and so that's helping put more
product into the market as well as the
Investments that you mentioned coming
from uh new for manufacturers especially
in electric vehicles we're able to get
more through into the customers hands
especially in The Fleets well that's
very moot point because obviously last
week the government has mandated the
industry with selling a certain
proportion of electric vehicles as part
of overall sales is the industry going
to hit next year's targets 22 I think
it's well you have to hit it um you know
this regular we've seen the consultation
announced last week There's regulation
coming in of the year
um the government's been very clear that
that's the trajectory that it wants to
see from the UK the challenge obviously
is that this is a really short time
frame to you know announce a
consultation on your regular relation to
start nine months later gives
manufacturers very little time to plan
their products what we are seeing in
terms of demand for electric vehicles is
whilst the numbers are going up the
market share is a bit static at the
moment so we need to overcome some of
the challenges of that part of that's
affordability but the biggest issue is
charging infrastructure people's
reticence to make the transition if you
can't be sure we're going to charge well
absolutely and what about the inventory
though I mean is the Infantry going to
be there this time next year to hit that
Target it's it's easy it depends just
how big the market is as I say I said we
expect the market to grow over the next
couple of years because we're in a long
period of recovery given something how
wretched the last three years were so
we're beginning to see an easing of that
Supply
um but you know the target for next year
will be 22 percent by brand of EVS for
the industry across the March just gone
it was 16.2 yeah that's I mean that's
really difficult for the likes of uh I
don't know Jaguar Land Rover for example
isn't it which have of course is still
very heavily geared to diesel there are
there's some flexibility that's been
proposed which allows you know certain
manufacturers you know if they they can
see they've got the launches come in the
next couple of years they can
effectively sort of borrow against that
because when that these companies make
that shift they'll make it quick quickly
and they'll make it in a big way so they
can every industry every brand is
heading towards that same destination
just on slightly different trajectories
and looking at longer term obviously the
EU has just watered down uh the the
targets by which the internal combustion
engine is going to be phased out the UK
government's sticking to it and odds
were already more ambitious than the EU
mistake yeah I think the government's
been very clear it's been zero means
zero but I think what we need to look at
is certain applications where
electrification might not in the
immediate term lend itself so readily a
lot of the focuses on cars and and vans
and they can Electrify but when you're
thinking about heavy Goods Vehicles
coaches for instance electrification may
not readily work for them so having an
open-minded approach to some of these
other Technologies which can still be
zero emission uh tailpipe can certainly
open up affordable transition to Net
Zero because if you're going to deliver
Net Zero you have to decarbonize Road
Transport in the meantime looking at uh
back to these latest figures these
monthly figures I mean in terms of
popularity among sales types it's still
the super mini yeah it's still I mean
it's this is one of the real one of the
issues for the industry because that is
still the biggest selling segment it's
one of the more affordable segments but
of course affordability and trying to
make that shift towards electrification
which is a more expensive technology
moment poses real challenges for the
industry how would you make affordable
vehicles with which are electric and in
demand by consumers it's a conundrum but
the level of investment is massive to
try and overcome that I take it that is
not necessarily the the super medes and
not necessarily what the big Fleet
buyers are going for right now Fair buy
mixture um and that's one of the more
encouraging things to see over the past
uh past month or two is that you know
because because of that releasing of
Supply you're able to fulfill some of
those demands there is still a long
order Bank
um but you know the what the great thing
about the market is is that diversity
and increasingly availability of
electric cars in all segments of the
market or I might go to leave it there
good to see you this morning thank you
we're going to go back now to uh the
breaking news that we brought you at the
top of the hour which is that the former
Scottish national party chief executive
Peter Murrell is understood to have been
arrested by police Scotland over an
investigation into the party's finances
Peter Morrell is of course the husband
of Nicholas sturgeon the former first
minister of Scotland our political
correspondent Tamara Cohen is in
Westminster tomorrow what have you
learned in the last 20 minutes or so
well in a pretty dramatic development
this morning as Peter Murrell we heard
had been arrested by detectives as part
of this investigation into the finances
and funding of the Scottish national
party we've seen this picture which is
police tape outside the home that moral
shares with Nicholas sturgeon we know
that the police are raiding a number of
addresses and this appears to be one of
them so I think the big question over
the coming days will be whether sturgeon
herself is dragged into this in any way
what this is all about it dates back to
the missing six hundred thousand pounds
this was a drive by the SMP to raise
funds for a second Independence
referendum began back in 2017 they
raised 667
000 pounds from activists over the years
and the complaint made to police was
that this money had gone missing they
could not account for very much of it to
the point that a couple of years ago the
SMP were are in such financial
difficulty that Peter Murrell who has
been chief executive of the SMP for more
than 20 years actually gave them a
personal loan of a hundred thousand
pounds and there were questions about
that and why it was not declared
properly so all of this has been looked
into by the police and we understand
that the police did actually speak to
other senior officials in the SMP in the
last week or two but now Mr Morrill has
been investiga is being arrested and is
being questioned over what happened
there so here Nicholas sturgeon very
much the power couple of the SMP over
the years he was also seen as key to the
smp's election success but now
um what he what he was doing behind the
scenes very much being called into
question
tomorrow we're getting getting reaction
now from some of the other political
parties in Scotland I gather the
Scottish labor party have called this a
deeply disturbing development
yes that's right I've just heard
actually from Ian Murray who's the
Labor's Shadow Scottish secretary and he
said this is a deeply concerning
development in the police Scotland
investigation must be allowed to proceed
without interference Mr Murray told me
for too long a culture of secrecy and
cover-up has been allowed to Fester at
the heart of the SMP we need the new
first Minister Hamza Yusuf and the
former first Minister Nicholas sturgeon
to urgently State what they knew and
when now you'll remember that Nicholas
sturgeon was asked at this press
conference when she made the shock
decision to resign as first minister in
February she was asked what she knew
about this 600 a thousand pounds and she
said she just wanted the police to do
their work she was asked in an interview
by Beth Rigby last month whether the
police had spoken to her in that part of
their investigation and she said no they
hadn't but the police certainly uh
seemed to be at the property now where
sturgeon and moral live and he's being
questioned by detectives this morning so
I'm sure we'll have opposition parties
rubbing their hands about this latest
development and it comes after concerns
had been expressed even within the SMP
ranks about the fact that there had been
such dominance over the Party by this
pair um you had Joanna Cherry SMP
um MP and she said like she said a
couple of years ago when this police
investigation began that Peter Murrell
should not continue as chief executive
and in fact when the police
investigation was first launched back in
2021 there were quite a few resignations
including of the party's Treasurer who
said that he'd not been given enough
information to do his job so it may well
be that quite a lot ends up coming out
in the coming months about who knew what
about the smps finances and after a
period in which Nicholas sturgeon was so
dominant and so incredibly popular as
SMP first Minister this could be a fall
from graceful for both of them
okay tomorrow thanks for that
[Music]
well the oil prices continue to
consolidate its gain since Sunday's
prize production cut by the OPEC plus
grouping but as you can see in the last
20 minutes price has gone negative
barrel of Brent crude currently changing
hands at 84.81 cents a barrel that's a
little under a sixth of one percent
lower on the session on the equity
markets last night sell-off on Wall
Street was followed by a lackluster
session in the Asia Pacific region
Sydney was unchanged Shanghai finished
higher Tokyo and Hong Kong both finished
low Mumbai which isn't on the screen
finished ahead by nearly one percent
though that was on some strong company
results well in Europe markets have been
largely in negative territory this
morning there you go that's the current
picture only the objects in Madrid in
positive territory talking points this
morning on Continental Europe include
Sodexo the French catering and Food
Services giant it shares up nine percent
in Paris or news it's spinning off one
of its subsidiaries we're here in London
the ftse 100 has been in positive
territory that remains the case it's up
nearly quarter of one percent led by
some utility and Healthcare stocks the
leading gainer in the ftse this morning
is uh United utilities that's on broker
comment that shares nearly uh three
percent to the good there well the Gold
Miner Endeavor mining its Shares are
also ahead that's after the gold price
hit its highest level since March last
year outside the ftse while we were
talking car registrations earlier on the
motor dealer Lookers is ahead by some
two percent on news that its annual
profits are going to come in ahead of
expectations while direct line which has
been pretty bummed out lately it shares
up four percent from the look at that
nearly six percent now that's a comment
from the Adolescent Citigroup they've
moved from sellers to buyers this
morning on the downside the water and
climate solutions group generate is down
nearly three percent on the unexpected
resignation of its Chief Operating
Officer meanwhile on the foreign
exchange markets for the big talking
point today has been the New Zealand
dollar which has jumped following a
bigger interest rate rise overnight than
expected from The Reserve Bank of New
Zealand the pound which yesterday hit a
10-month high against the US dollar
currently off by just over a quarter one
percent against both the dollar and the
Euro The single currency meanwhile
unchanged against the Greenback will
joining me this morning is the head of
investment at interactive investor
Victoria scholar Victoria good to see
you this morning
um let's start with entertain I
mentioned them earlier in the program
the owner of lab Brooks and coral quite
quite a big acquisition from them this
morning
yeah that's right it's Sequoia Sports
media business 365 scores for its entire
share capital for a consideration of 150
million dollars with a payment of up to
10 million dollars uh this is the owner
of ladbroken coral of course and the
deal it says will provide a broader
offering of interactive content and
experiences now we know that there have
been many many Acquisitions within this
sector over time but this one's a bit
different because the sports betting
giant is getting into content and I
think it really highlights the
importance of data when companies are
trying to Target new audiences now but
entain has had a bit of a tough time
lately in stark contrast to its rival
flutter which is one of the best
performing stocks on the ftse 100 over
the last year there was speculation that
entain could have been acquired by MGM
Resorts earlier in the year we were
looking for another bid that didn't
materialize eyes and so now that Eminem
m a premium appears to be fading and
Weighing on its share price absolutely
now what about the pound Victoria hit a
10 month High yesterday so come off a
little bit this morning but I mean
Sterling is probably the best performing
major currency this year this is all
about interest rate expectations of
course
it is it feels as though King Dollar is
losing its Crown we know that the green
bat was very much in favor among
investors last year when we got that
aggressive phase of rate hikes from the
fed this year things are turning around
we're heading towards the peak of the
fed's rate hiking cycle and there are
fears of a U.S recession and that's kind
of taking the wind out of the sails of
uh the dollar and other currencies
including the pound are benefiting from
that which is why Sterling has rallied
to a 10-month high we also had some
disappointing U.S data out yesterday U.S
manufacturing data came in soft and job
openings as well the labor market has
been a bright spot for the US economy
but even that is struggling now again
raising fears of a U.S recession and so
we're seeing that flight away from the
dollar towards other currencies instead
we did get that speech yesterday from
Hugh Phil the bank's Chief Economist of
course in which he hinted at uh further
rate Rises I mean what interested me
most was the fact that we got this big
rate rise overnight from The Reserve
Bank of New Zealand really caught the
markets on the Hop a reminder I guess
that central banks do like to catch
people by surprise on occasions
yeah you're right and it's really
interesting when we compare it to what
we saw from Australia with the Reserve
Bank for Australia keeping rates on hold
this week but New Zealand has decided to
power ahead with this more hawkish move
a 50 basis point rise whereas the
markets were anticipating a 25 basis
point increase so it seems to suggest
that New Zealand it continues to be
concerned about the inflationary
backdrop and it's taking steps
accordingly in terms of monetary policy
to try to alleviate those price
pressures
all right Victoria gotta leave it there
good to see you this morning thank you
just a reminder of the breaking news
story this morning the arrest of Peter
Murrell the former chief executive of
the Scottish national party on the side
of the screen there you can see the
property that has been visited by police
Scotland this morning we'll have more on
that story throughout the morning here
on Sky News
but now if you've worked in civil
engineering construction surveying or
transport you may well be familiar with
the UK US company Trimble the 13 billion
dollar Technology Solutions Group which
was a Pioneer in the use of GPS
satellite technology supports Field
Mobile workers and Professionals in a
range of Industries which also include
land and agriculture it's just completed
the near two billion dollar acquisition
of a German rival transport in which
specializes in supporting customers in
shipping and logistics for joining me
now is the chief executive of Trimble
Robert painter Robert painter very good
morning to you thank you for joining me
it's such an unsociable hour
um this acquisition I guess was all
about expanding your footprint further
into Europe was it
indeed transporting is a leading
transportation management platform
company based in Europe which makes a
really nice compliment to the business
that we have that's primarily Been a
North American Business in the
transportation industry really a a
wonderful team doing great things on the
continent
it makes you of course a much bigger
player in terms of servicing Logistics
and Freights groups what's the sentiment
among customers in that sector right now
well when we think about the customers
we have we serve both carriers and
shippers um in the transportation market
and on a global basis Transportation
really is a business where you need to
get something from point x to point Y
um and in doing so you need to connect
the carriers and the shippers and so
what customers seeing us doing right now
is densifying the network bringing more
carriers and more shippers together when
you bring more industry participants
together and you can help help them
solve higher order problems um you're
doing right by your customers so the
feedback we're hearing thus far is very
positive
of those sectors now fully adapted to
changing circumstances following the
invasion of Ukraine
um well I'd say what has changed with
the invasion of Ukraine and our
customers is it certainly thrown
disruptions into the supply chain
throwing disruptions um and to actually
even to labor markets you know many
drivers in uh in the continent in Europe
actually come from Ukraine so there's
been disruptions everything from the
drivers through the supply chains and
the carriers and shippers it's just
become more complex
um and to manage that complexity
technology has a role now looking at
your latest results you're all across
many sectors you've got customers in
many many sectors it looks as though
your earnings growth is is currently
most strong in supporting uh areas like
forestry and utilities
well actually the earnings growth um has
been pretty strong across um all parts
of Trimble you know construction on a
global basis continues to be one of the
very largest Industries in the world and
we've seen coming out of uh the the
recovery post covet as many countries
have invested into infrastructure and
that's been a positive Catalyst for our
business and our agriculture business
commodity prices have continued to be
high and that correlates to the war in
Ukraine certainly that's made farm
income strong and that's allowed Farmers
to invest back into our Technologies and
then we talk about the the complexities
in the supply chain that are being
managed which has been a catalyst for
growth and transportation you do do some
quite interesting things with farming
customers I gather one initiative has
has been to help them make optimal use
of pesticides and reduce it where
possible
indeed you know so we're a company um
with roots and GPS Technologies and so
we like um High Precision um models both
High Precision in the field and high
Precision planning models in in the
office it's really that intersection of
work in the physical and the digital
world so on a farm um you know if you
need centimeter accuracy which you do to
optimize the yield of crop and minimize
the use of inputs you're using Trimble
technology we'll create a digital map of
a farm that could tell you where to put
more or less fertilizer depending on the
health of the soil on the farm so by
optimizing where you put that fertilizer
you can minimize the use you can bring
the input costs down from the farm or
increase the yield of the crop and and
create more environmental sustainability
while doing so
and looking more broadly at the world
obviously you we've been in a very very
uh sharply uh Rising interest rate
environment for the last 12 months also
are you surprised at the extent to which
cons spending by your customers has held
up
um I'm not that surprised and I'll tell
you why is that when you're using the
the technology that we have at Trimble
the fundamental value proposition comes
in the form of better faster safer
cheaper Greener so that that that
productivity that you get from using the
technology and we kind of help eliminate
30 of waste um that takes place in
transportation we can make earth moving
equipment 50 percent more productive so
as interest rates go up and businesses
have to be more competitive you need
technology more than ever to help you do
your work more efficiently
all right Rob Payne said we've got to
leave it there really appreciate you
joining us at such an unsociable hour
thank you thanks again
now today marks the end of the current
tax year meaning you have just a few
hours left to make the most of your
pension or ice or allowance for 2020 23.
while the end of the taxi is
traditionally a time when people
scramble to top up their Isa this year
is also expected to see a lot more
activity as investors move to
crystallize capital gains ahead of a big
cut in the capital gains tax-free
allowance that kicks in tomorrow we'll
joining me now is Chris Hill he's chief
executive of Hargreaves Lansdowne which
runs the UK's biggest savings and
Investments platform Chris good to see
you again
um are you seeing a busier than normal
enter the tax year with these capital
gains tax changes coming in
morning thanks for having me back uh yes
we are seeing it it's always a busy time
for us I mean this will be this will be
my seventh uh tax year end at Hargreaves
Lansdowne and uh I think they're all
special in their own their own unique
way but possibly this one the most
important for a generation as you say
we've got capital gains tax changes
we've got changes to the dividend
allowance and then of course from
Tomorrow the changes in the pension
rules are announced there's no lifetime
allowance so I think we'll then see you
know significant interest in people
investing into those pensions and all of
that clearly happening in the context of
a um crisis of um you know living cost
of living crisis
um and I think that also is having
challenges on how people are reacting
through the tax year end well tell me
more I mean uh are people able to put
away as much in in this environment
well I think that's what's interesting
you see I mean we always have a busy tax
year end and uh why you know we all
leave it to the last minute clearly
people do and I'll be with colleagues up
until about midnight still taking the
calls today but I think what's also
happened is because of the um the cost
of living crisis people have waited to
see how much they've got available to
then go ahead and save and also given
the volatility of markets at the moment
we're seeing a lot of interest in cash
so four out of the top 10 funds that
people are investing at the moment are
cash funds now I've never seen that
before and I think certainly the
increase in interest rates and people
knowing that they can get a return of
four four and a half percent on their
cash means that they're holding back
from investing and I think at some stage
we'll see that swing as people take that
longer term View
now on the program yesterday we were
speaking to Archie Norman the Marx and
Spencer chief executive chairman who's
running a campaign at the moment to
restore closer links between
shareholders and the companies they
invest in I mean you're a big provider
of nominee Services you you have a big
role to play here potentially
well yes we are the we're the biggest UK
investment platform we've got 1.8
million clients now so we certainly see
ourselves as flying the flag for retail
investors and um there's no doubt that
retail investing is a growing and it
will be a significant force uh in
investment in UK Capital markets and
it's really important that UK retail
shareholders are able to to have their
say I mean of the top 10
shares that people are investing in to
tax your end they're all UK companies
and UK investors are big supporters of
the domestic economy in UK companies
sure they want diversification but they
do want to invest in UK companies so
it's really important that they have
their voice
you've actually just launched a digital
service which enables uh shareholders to
cast their votes more easily what sort
of take-up have you had on that
significant I think we are at four or
five times the level before and I think
there's more work we can do there to
help people to engage and understand and
as a consequence they'll want to you
know vote their shares which I think is
a significant step up as far as
shareholder engagement is concerned it's
quite interesting I mean you talk just
now about the importance of retail
investors I mean something like 60 of
Americans have shareholdings you know
there are invested in the stock market
it's only about a third of britons why
is that that difference do you think
well I think it's developing I mean over
uh over my time as Co we doubled the
size of this business so we're now at
1.8 million clients and throughout that
time we've seen a steady increasing uh
investment in shares particularly
accelerated through the the pandemic as
well but you know the the American
Savings the 401K how people manage their
pensions encourages much more direct
engagement direct ownership of your
financial savings your financial future
we're moving that way Define benefit
pensions are um declining now over time
so it's all about defined contribution
as a consequence it's all about
individuals taking their own provision
into their own control and that's why
retail investing is just going to be so
significant as sources are capped
unsources investment over the next five
ten plus years
all right Chris I know it's a hugely
busy day for you and the team you'll be
burning the midnight all today I imagine
thanks very much for spending the time
to speak to us
thanks Ian Take Care thank you very much
we're going to go back now to the
breaking news that we brought you at the
top of the hour the former Scottish
national party chief executive and
husband of the former first Minister
Nicholas sturgeon Peter Morrell is
understood to have been arrested by
police Scotland over an investigation
into the party's finances our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillies joins me
now from Glasgow uh Connor what's the
latest
yeah this is the center of a major
police investigation right now let's
take a look uh new officers just arrived
on the scene within the last few minutes
and fresh uh barriers being put up that
is the home of Peter model the man in
custody the man being questioned by
detectives right now as part of this
live ongoing police investigation also
the home of the former first minister of
Scotland Nicholas sturgeon who left
office just a matter of days ago this
area is swarming with police this is the
area where they both share a home and we
understand evidence is being gathered
and at the same time Mr Morrow is in
custody you can see a number of officers
continuing to come out of that house and
clearly this is a tent that is usually
erected for the most serious police
investigations and here we have it
outside the home of the former first
minister of Scotland and the former
chief executive of the Scottish national
party let's just take you around for a
Luke round at the other side of uh the
street here this is a busy street so
let's just watch how we go here but you
can see a number of police vehicles
which arrived very early this morning as
part of this inquiry another angle there
the curtains firmly closed on this home
this property of Peter motto and
Nicholas sturgeon and of course this is
an investigation centered on party
finances and funding let's take you
around the other side here
um because
as part of this investigation there have
been questions around a loan of around a
hundred thousand pounds Peter Morrow
gave to the Scottish national party and
also questions around 600 000 pounds
that was raised for the cause of
Independence for the cause of a second
vote on Scottish independence and there
have been questions around where
that money is now clearly that may or
may not be forming part of this live
investigation but again this is another
angle a number of officers standing
guards here the body are stretching
around the side of this property and a
car parked in the drive still on charge
there the curtains firmly closed
um as police gather evidence inside that
tent and at the same time
at the man at the center of this
investigation Peter Model A man who was
in charge of the SMP since 1999 and
resigned in a shock resignation just a
number of weeks ago after so many years
at the helm there was questions around
whether he had misled a reporter had
misled the press and in turn misled the
public around dwindling party numbers
membership numbers at a time when the
leadership content the leadership
contenders vying to the police Nicola
sturgeon here in Scotland were asking
exactly how many members were voting in
that contest it appears that that was
not forthcoming and a journalist was
apparently misled and later it was
revealed the party had lost around
thirty thousand members that is a
separate matter here the focus is very
much on the finances of the SMP the
funding of the SNP and it is quite an
extraordinary moment the home of the
former first minister of Scotland now at
the center of this live police
investigation at the same time Nicholas
sturgeon's husband in custody facing
questions after so many years that power
couple at the top of Scottish politics
and the snp's office in Edinburgh the
headquarters just around the corner from
the Scottish Parliament is a very
similar scene a number of police
officers a number of police cars while
raids are continuing on that property
what evidence will they or will they not
find in there Nicholas sturgeon let's go
back around here Nicholas sturgeon
during an interview with Sky News just a
number of weeks ago told us that she nor
her husband were aware of interviews
being gathered taking place as part of
this investigation that was just a week
of her resignation well how long will
that position stand for will there be
fresh questions about what the former
first Minister knew what she she did not
know her position is firmly she did not
know anything about the finances the
state of the finances as well of the
Scottish national party
um but it is quite an extraordinary
moment let's go back around for one
final look here as more police continue
to swarm this area specialist detectives
and officers uh looks like they are
re-entering the property right now let's
just take a look at this moment here
going behind that protective barrier and
inside what appears to be the front door
of the model household the sturgeon
model household here on the outskirts of
Edinburgh discussions around a possible
loan that Peter Morrow did or did not
give to the SMP of around a hundred
thousand pounds and separate questions
around 600
000 pounds of money that was raised for
the cause of Independence will that be
part of this investigation that is
something these detectives are hoping to
get to the bottom of
very good Corner thanks for that while
you've been speaking uh we can
definitively now say that Peter Morrow
has been arrested previously we were
saying it is understood he's been
arrested we can now definitively say
that Peter Morrell husband of the former
first minister of Scotland Nicholas
sturgeon has been arrested in connection
with an investigation into the party
finances much more on that to come here
this morning but in the meantime a bit
more breaking news to bring you which is
that talks with Royal Mail and the
communication Workers Union have
concluded without agreement uh we've got
this spokesperson from the Royal Mail a
statement which says after 11 months of
talks including mediation by Sir Brandon
Barber and acas we are deeply concerned
that our talks with the CW have
concluded without an agreement we made
substantial efforts to reach an
agreement including making a number of
further improvements to our offer these
improvements were all based on feedback
from the CW and we were hopeful that the
union would put a deal to its members we
remain committed to reaching an
agreement with the CWU we have been
clear throughout the dispute that not
Transforming Our Network and working
practices is not an option in a business
losing more than one million pounds a
day in the best interest of the business
our customers and the job security of
our post-men and women change cannot be
delayed any further I'm back at 10
o'clock tomorrow hopefully we'll bring
you the uh end of the year Archie Norman
interview that I promised you this time
yesterday Anna Jones is up next do stay
tuned cheerio
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
ERS today it's 11 o'clock the headlines
Nicholas sturgeon's husband the former
SNP chief executive Peter Murrell is
arrested in an investigation into party
funding
we're live outside the couple's house in
Glasgow where police activity is
continuing
more breaking news is our Sky News
understands the home office will confirm
today that this giant barge will house
up to 500 migrants indoorses
also this morning this is the scene live
as president zielinski meets his polish
counterpart in his first official visit
to Ukraine's neighbor since the War
Began
forgotten victims we hear the stories of
the children of convicted sex offenders
I am not allowed to say his name in
school because I will get attacked by my
friends everyone says I can't love him
but
I can't stop
after pleading and not guilty to 34
criminal charges Donald Trump tells
supporters the U.S is going to hell
this fake case was brought only to
interfere with the upcoming 2024
election
and it should be dropped immediately
immediately
[Applause]
and consult no more Queen Camilla's
post-coronation title is used for the
first time on the invitations to next
month's ceremony
[Music]
hello very good morning Nicholas
surgeon's husband Peter Murrell has been
arrested by police investigating the
funding and finances of the Scottish
national party Mr Morrill stood down as
the party's chief executive last month